the other thing mainstream media does
when they're laundering the lies they
take disgraced people so Donna Brazil
you remember Donna Brazil she was the
head of the Democrat National Convention
she didn't do very well there so then
she became a CNN correspondent and then
as a CNN correspondent she actually gave
one of the presidential debate questions
to Hillary Clinton which was not allowed
so she had to resign in disgrace then
she became a Fox News correspondent
after that well here she's back she just
comes back like Freddy Krueger you got
to bury the bones she's back and uh yeah
she's also trying to scare the hell out
of you over Ron DeSantis because
apparently she wants her children to be
taught about racism and chopping
genitals off videotape but Ron DeSantis
is running on a 1950s America not a 2050
America America the future so I think
Joe Biden will have a real good
Advantage going into the 2024. now I
should
Joe Biden will not have an advantage
well I understand you guys will do
everything possible to give him an
advantage but he won't even know what
year it is in 2024. Ron DeSantis look
you know what's funny when we were going
through this clip I was thinking does
Rhonda Sanders want to take us back to
1950s America what does that mean
well first off the way she's framing it
of course that's not what he wants to
take him take America back to the way
she's framing it the implication is when
America was truly racist and homophobic
and blah blah blah uh but in another
framing of that you could say maybe we
should go a little bit backwards we're
always going forwards progressives are
always taking us forward but progress
for the sake of progress is in good
progress for the sake of equality is
good but you don't want to always just
progress no matter what sometimes you're
progressing and you're going real fast
and you're progressing and then you
realize oh the road ends and it goes off
a cliff that's basically what they're
trying to do to us right now I would say
that in 1950s America for the flaws that
we had and we certainly had things that
we needed to take care of and Civil
Rights Act and a whole bunch of other
things and we did get more equality over
the years and marriage equality and
things of that nature but we weren't
suffering from this Mass delusion of
lunacy that boys or girls and girls or
boys and it was not being taught uh in
mainstream America that racism was okay
even really even in the 50s maybe in
some places in the South but it was it
was not part of the culture and again we
fought a war
fairly close to our founding to end
slavery but these these hucksters and
grifters it never ends
foreign
[Music]